you saw Elon asked Mr Beast to post on X
yeah and then Beast was like
nah he's got the network is called the
Tucker Carlson Network and has eight
different vertical wi in there or like
shows like he has his tour the sworn
enemy tour he's got like the cabin
interviews that he does so he can be
suited up political interviewer Tucker
Tucker is sharp he's well read he like
zins that's cool yeah he's into the Zen
yeah no the um yeah the Mr Beast uh can
I see what he said oh the Mr Beast thing
yeah yeah basically he was like uh I
upload it go watch it I'll drop kick you
and then someone was like upload on this
platform too Elon says yeah and then he
says my videos cost Millions to make and
even if they got a billion views on X it
wouldn't fund a fraction of it oh
[__] which I mean YouTube pays the most
it seems like of this type of content
yeah
so damn I mean yeah if if Twitter's not
paying any AD Revenue can he do it I
said I'm down though to test stuff once
monetization is really cranking yeah
yeah he needs to make money I think what
he's thinking is if I post it on Twitter
it's going to take away from my views on
YouTube which generate Revenue yeah so
I'm losing money to promote your
platform now what Elon should be doing
is going here's the check yeah we're
going to pay you more than you would
make on YouTube to just also post here
yeah post here because that hurts cuz
he's also got Twitter blue which is
where they're they're advertising people
are making so much on Twitter using
Twitter blue and if Mr Beast is like no
I'm not then I'm I'm like oh maybe I
don't need this [__] blue cheick I
was thinking about getting it and I
might still do it but whenever the
special comes out I was like maybe I put
it on Twitter get the blue it monetizes
too and now I'm looking at it like oh
you don't make that much yeah maybe it's
a bad move yeah yeah they got to figure
out just how to like get actual money
off these views which is the biggest
challenge for all these platforms like
short form views specifically like how
do you really make money off yeah it's
just tough yeah I mean what d advantage
that you know Tik Tok has is that you
get lost in that scroll so they can
throw an ad as the fifth swipe up yeah
Twitter is a little different in that
your scroll is the feed it's kind of an
Antiquated model where it's like you're
just being you're just being like um
almost force-fed these things that and
most of the stuff on your feet is people
you follow but I think they also throw
other things they think you'll like but
Tik Tok is the geni Tik Tok is like
they're like we know what you like you
don't got to tell us yeah and we're
gonna Fe a full swipe I can't do one
swipe and get go past 10 tweets yeah
100% you know what else that tweet makes
it feel like is oh y'all are y'all can't
afford to pay yeah y'all can't afford to
pay you're still
broke yeah maybe yo let's y put a put
$10 now price pick going to multiply the
[__] out of it if you get all that's
right they're going to match your
initial deposit up to a 100 bucks okay
simple is that you go to prize pick use
the code Schultz prize.com use the code
Schultz
SZ they're going to match your initial
deposit up to $100 you put in 100 they
put in 100 you take the aash sing locks
and you generate some real Revenue we
know it's the first of the new year you
spent all your money on Christmas
presents spent all your money on a crazy
New Year party time to get a little bit
more in your pockets and let prize picks
do it for you did you see the the Cyber
truck ad quote unquote that was great
like did you see this basically this
went viral it was like yo cyber truck
got in its first accident here's what
happened and this is the picture of the
Cyber truck fantastic and this is the
picture of the Corolla that it hit holy
absolutely
fantastic I I don't know if it's really
an ad but this [__] feels like it it
just looks so good for the cybertruck
it's an amazing ad if it is now here's
the question do we have the
list EP list do we have [__] ep's
list yet let me find out how do we not
have ep's list I'm starting to really
think this is going to be so
underwhelming it is no list yet no
[__] list um
um what do we think about this Tasha K
Kevin Hart thing I mean she's been sued
like left and right yeah she's been sued
a few times for defamation yeah I I
didn't know who she was I had heard the
name but I was watching her videos
yesterday when the story but this is
extortion she's suing him for so
defamation was cardi B this one is she
was literally allegedly trying to extort
Kevin Hart with his assistant G me
and I won't post this video and it's
like that's a that's a crime talking
[__] about somebody or saying something
is podcasting yeah now once these
lawsuits start getting thrown out might
change podcasting we might have to throw
a lot more allegedly out yeah you know